[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with columnist
carol malone and journalist and author
peter gagan velvia with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
uk shuts down in bid to save christmas
reads the front of the eye as omicron
numbers threaten christmas plans
it's beginning to look a lot like
christmas says the sun as they report
that pubs are in crisis
the metro leads on her majesty the queen
cancelling her traditional christmas
lunch
the daily mail has the headline tories
turn on witty after the chief medical
officer's latest announcement
the front of the telegraph quotes the
archbishop of canterbury who's spoken of
his disappointment over tory gatherings
during lockdown
the tory's alleged rule breaking is also
the focus for the mirror which reports
the met police have plans to interview
two people about the aids party last
christmas
the financial times focuses on the bank
of england raising interest rates for
the first time in three years
joining me tonight carol malone and
peter gagan welcome to you both um let's
start with the eye and their headline uk
shuts down in bid to save
christmas um it's rather jumping at the
gun i know they've been criticisms that
boris johnson is bringing in lockdown by
stealth but we're not actually there yet
are we carol
well we're not but we're kind of being
guilted into it by
um not just by chris whittie but by
boris himself we're being
we're being told not to cancel things
but we've been told to prioritize and
the whole the idea i think is they're
saying don't say your friends don't go
to pubs don't go to parties if you want
to see your family at christmas and so
it is a sort of a lock down by itself
and it is sort of telling us that we
have to be super careful i mean witty
today has been doom-mongering for most
of the day and yesterday and i don't
quite know how he's allowed to do that
he's not a an elected representative
he's not a politician he's a scientist
who has been epically wrong throughout
this pandemic and yet he's talking about
what's going on with with these
restrictions for the next 18 months
without any consultation with government
he's deciding that's going to be the
case and he doesn't know how bad omicron
is yet no one knows if it's going to be
bad in fact many eminent scientists say
it isn't going to be any worse than a
common cold so witty is jumping the gun
and he's actually it's irresponsibly
scaremongering he's terrifying people
which is why a lot of people are
canceling things for christmas it's why
the hospitality industry is panicking
right now and pubs 3.2 million
customers cancelled over the past week
because of witty scaremongering
peter is uh professor chris witte a
scaremonger
i don't know if it's any i don't know
i'm not convinced that it's professor
chris which he's doing that we are
seeing from pages like this you know i
think you know most people's experience
over recent days certainly mine and a
lot of people i know too has been
lots of contacts coming down we've
covered lots of pings on phones lots of
people they know having symptoms waiting
for test results and that's been backed
up by you know by the statistics we're
on 90 000 cases a day so with that level
of exposure that level of covert in the
community it's not really that
surprising i think i think people are
voting with their feet not necessarily
listening that much to government
scientists but just from what they can
see around them and in many ways we have
been here before there's a lot of echoes
of christmas 2020. i think a lot of
people remember what january and
february of 2020 were like in terms of
the rates of infection the amount of
people in hospitals obviously when the
difference is now we do have vaccines we
do boosters but the concern is that the
sheer scale of this so if you look at
the data from south africa what they're
showing is so far it looks like it's
about about roughly 30 so far
uh less um likely to lead to
hospitalization than the delta variant
they're very primitive numbers but the
numbers of people being infected the or
number that crucial or number four
omicron at the moment is is between
three and five
that's a huge order of magnitude heavier
and i think a lot of people people are
sensible people are you know people are
used to this i don't think the idea that
government scientists alone can dictate
how people act i think is probably not
really reflective of reality and all
through this pandemic feels as if
actually the public and people have been
quite ahead particularly of the
government and it probably feels like
this again and it's like one it's one of
those things you can't really you're in
the same way that when the government
tried to tell people to go back to the
office and they were quite resistant to
you're going to find the same thing here
like government can advise government
can lay out the groundwork but people
are going to act with their own
instincts and in many ways it's not
surprising to see given just the sheer
volume of uh this virus that we
currently have in the community carol do
you think uh peter's writing that that
people are sensible or are they less
likely this time around to listen to the
advice
i just want to say so i just want to get
into something he said there that 30
percent of people who in south africa
are in hospital there's a real world
report have come out today a study of 78
000 omicron uh people who've had omicron
it's saying that only five percent of
those people needed um intensive care as
opposed to nearly 30 of those who had
delta and you know you know we're saying
that you know
you know you don't shut down a country
for a strain of a virus that many
scientists are saying is no worse than a
cold and that's what we're doing and
that's where the scaremongering comes in
because whitty is saying things like you
know a year ago he was saying we needed
a vaccine before we could lift
restrictions now he's saying we need
another kind of vaccine that is going to
take care of all the other variants
before we can lift restrictions and some
people in sage are saying we're going to
have this nonsense for the next five
years these guys don't know that this is
just speculation this is hysteria and
speculation and that is why people are
canceling stuff it's not because they're
they're they're they're just being
sensible they're afraid many people
they're
lots of people are still afraid from
last year and they're even more afraid
now because they're being told this
variant could be the worst yet it isn't
what we have to look at is not how many
people get this 88 000 cases today but
how that translates into
hospitalizations and deaths and it's not
doing that in south africa and it's not
doing that here and peter we have heard
from the uh the medic that uh was
responsible for finding this uh strain
omicron in south africa saying that it's
it's
not as bad by any means as uh the delta
variant and really that we perhaps
shouldn't overreact in in this country
should we ignore her her advice
i don't think it's a matter of ignoring
anyone's advice you know i think there's
a like i am not a scientist none of us
are scientists frankly on this program
so i think
it is worth laying out that so none of
us are really in a particularly
fantastic place to give out national
health advice and a pandemic but it is
striking
whatever your health background just to
see the sheer scale of this the figures
previously quoted are quite odd 55 of
people with delta variant didn't end up
in hospital are of uh of uh delta
variant and like you're talking about
less than one percent of
hospitalizations for any any strain of
covert so far if it had been any higher
we would see much higher mortality rates
with it but the sheer and the sheer
scale of its spread in the united
kingdom in particular which it seems to
be greater than pretty much anywhere in
the world is really really huge i'm just
not surprised i don't i just don't think
this is surprising i'm surprised people
are surprised that people wouldn't stay
away from pubs and restaurants
at this time given the spread of of the
the virus itself i just
i'm slightly baffled by that maybe i
just don't understand people and maybe
they're all sitting watching boris
johnson and chris whittier making
judgments based only on that or maybe
they're making judgments based on the
fact of the last 18 months and the
reality of deciding to spread which i'm
sure i i can't be the only person that's
getting pings on their phone and texts
from friends saying i've just tested
positive my sense given the scale of it
especially here in london is that's
happening to lots of people and
unsurprisingly they're they're acting
with their feet
meanwhile
carol the the male is pointing to
divisions in the conservative party over
the the pronouncements of chris whitney
isn't it
yeah i mean it isn't and rightly so look
at and i said earlier whitty is not an
elected representative
he is not a politician and yet he is the
man who has caused lots of confusion
with people because while boris is
saying we're not locking down you know
people have got to do what they want to
do we're not closing stuff woody on the
other hand is is actually talking about
about this being the worst it may turn
out to be the worst one of the things he
said today which is incredible but he
said he kept saying stuff like i'm not
saying this will happen but it's
certainly possible yet world war iii is
certainly possible but it's not likely
to happen neither is what he's saying
which is this could be the worst lot of
hospital admissions we've ever had and
could and could actually swamp the nhs
he does not know that is gonna happen
and yet he's saying it and he's just
kind of i think he's just gone off piste
on his own
a scientist should not be allowed to
stand apart from the government and make
his own policy and scare people in the
way that whitty is doing it's quite
right that mps are turning against him
because he know what he says has a
massive impact on the economy you know
he's been he's single-handedly almost
putting a wrecking ball through this
very fragile recovery we have we know
that one of the reasons the bank of
england is having to put interest rate
ups today is because they're terrified
omicron is gonna is gonna set back the
recovery so people like witty aren't
helping in that may he is just sitting
there he has to bear none of the
responsibility for what he says he can
speculate and pontificate all he likes
and none of what he says might ever come
to pass and actually very little of what
whitty has said has ever come to pass
and yet he's allowed to just go out
there and say it scared both of you
let's have a look at the metro to start
with and uh her majesty the queen
pictured there because the story is
she's uh cancelling her pre-christmas
lunch with her family for why peter
yes so we have uh the story of the queen
well like like a lot of people the queen
is also uh cancelling her christmas
lunch uh this year we we were just
talking about that before the break
about the number of people that that's
happening too it's because you know
she's
it's a response to the surge of a
infections as we're seeing kind of
across the country she says decided to
put too many people's christmas
arrangements at risk and cancel it with
great regret um and it's the metro's
reporting a decision echoes the choices
that millions of britons must make in
the coming days as cases of the covered
variant rise and you know in some ways
you know once again the queen is
probably
i don't know if she was listening to
professor wishy but the the queen is uh
kind of acting
like lots of other people it seems and
cancelling her christmas plans yeah
setting a good example carol
here she is and i think that's exactly
what this is about you know i you know
this is this launch is a big deal for
the queen every year it's usually held
in buckingham palace and it's the
kickoff to all the christmas um
festivities and for her to have to
cancel this is a big thing and i think
she's been watching the news closely and
she's saying what's happening and she
doesn't want to be accused of of
partying with her family while other
families around the country are having
to cancel stuff and put stuff off and
not go to things so i think she's taking
responsibility very seriously but you
know this is a big thing every year is
to say that i mean two years ago megan
was pulling christmas crackers with
prince charles which isn't gonna happen
anytime soon but this is this is the the
lunch where she gets to see all her
grandkids way edward and sophie go where
sarah and mike tyndall go with their
kids kate and wills take their kids
because a lot of these people can't all
go to sandringham for the big christmas
lunch there so this is the one occasion
she gets to see the entire family so for
her to have to cancel this is a big deal
but like the queen always does she
always puts the country first and she's
thinking that this is the right thing to
do this is the this she will have had i
mean we've been talking about this for
two days now would she wouldn't she and
i think the mirror is carrying a story
today saying she was still thinking
about it but i think sense has ruled her
advisers are telling her that it's the
right thing to do and she will think but
also go remember this is quite sad
because it's the first christmas that
she has without prince philip so it's
kind of a sex
yes indeed um peter you've only got
about 30 seconds um to tell me how uh
covert is affecting our pocket as well
as our our christmas lunches this is the
financial times the interest rise
yes the bank of england have risen have
size rise interest rates um seemingly
they're hoping that's going to
stamp down inflation which seems
slightly unlikely given that a lot of
inflation seems to be driven by oil and
gas prices and supply and train problems
so
it probably probably instilled for a bit
of inflation into the new year despite
this rise